e3 as we know it is gone the esa the
show's organizers announced that not
only was the physical event in los
angeles off for 2022 but so was the
official digital component but without
e3 how are we going to get our summer
fix of gaming news and reveals
[Music]
have no fear jeff keeley is here and
once again he's got summer game fest
complete with all the world premieres we
can handle here's everything you need to
know about summer game fest and all the
other events and press conferences
during that time returning from last
year the warhammer skulls showcase will
be held on june 1st and will feature
games set in the warhammer and warhammer
40k universes from a wide variety of
developers and publishers including xbox
sega and meta quest expect a whole bunch
of world premieres for new warhammer
games as well as updates for total war
warhammer 3 vermintide 2 and battle
sector the next playstation state of
play event will be happening just before
most of the big not e3 presentations
kick off but it doesn't sound like it's
gonna be the giant press conference that
we want sony says it will focus on third
party partner reveals alongside looks at
games in development for psvr 2.
playstation doesn't mention other first
party games so we might not see god of
war ragnarok or other high-profile
exclusives here either
netflix geeked week is as the name
implies a week-long celebration of the
company's many science fiction and
fantasy properties complete with panels
trailers and according to netflix at
least some quote draw dropping surprises
each day of the show offers something
different monday is a look at upcoming
series like the third season of the
umbrella academy the live-action
resident evil and most excitingly for me
at least a look at the adaptation of
neil gaiman's the sandman tuesday offers
a look at upcoming movies coming to the
streaming service and on wednesday june
8th we'll get a look at cyberpunk
edgerunners edgerunners is an anime
spin-off of cyberpunk 2077 and it's made
by some of the best anime talent out
there studio trigger you might know them
as the makers of kill the kill and promo
thursday june 9th is stranger things day
but friday is all about those games baby
with looks at the cuphead show sonic
prime dota dragon's blood tekken
bloodline and 10 plus netflix games
e3 is out key three is in arguably the
biggest event of the summer games
event week whatever you want to call it
is jeff keeley's summer game fest
extravaganza which kicks off with the
two hour summer game fest live
presentation jeff will once again be
hosting and the show promises a slew of
world premieres keeley called the event
a cross industry showcase so expect
announcements from a wide range of
companies while everyone's obviously
keeping tight-lipped my fingers are
crossed at more glimpses from upcoming
2022 games like the callisto protocol
and gotham knights it's tough to say at
this point if the show will have as many
heavy hitters as last year remember when
it ended with that elden ring mic drop
but if anyone's going to be able to pull
in some big names it's jeff summer game
fest will also feature day of the devs
an indie showcase celebrating its 10th
year curated by psychonauts 2 developer
double fine and creative production
company i am 8bit
summer gamefest live will be broadcast
right here on gamespot or you can check
it out in select imax theaters if you
want to see those games in crispy high
definition dazzling images on a huge
silver screen somehow
heartbreak feels good in a place like
this on june 10th we get the tribeca
games spotlight a showcase that will
feature exclusive gameplay and
interviews from tribeca's official
selection of games not only that but you
can even play the games from the comfort
of your own home all you need is a
decent internet connection an xbox
controller or keyboard and mouse
depending on the game and a tribeca at
home games pass the pass is 5 bucks and
will allow you to play 20 to 30 minutes
of up to three games from a list that
includes a plague tale requiem cuphead
the delicious last course thirsty
suitors wenber and oxenfree 2. the
guerrilla collective stream will take
place on saturday june 11th it's a
digital showcase that'll have some new
announcements as well as gameplay
alongside the showcase there'll be a
steam page where you can wishlist the
games immediately as well as download
demos for certain titles the guerrilla
collective streams tend to be pretty
lengthy as not only do they feature a
huge amount of games but they also
include interviews with the developers
that make them afterwards is the
wholesome direct a showcase of upcoming
cozy indie games along with new gameplay
announcements and interviews last year's
showcase featured upwards of 70 games
including unpacking cat cafe manager
lake and the upcoming we are ofk the
future games show will once again return
for 2022 this year on june 11th it's
going to be featuring roughly 40 games
across xbox playstation switch and pc it
will be the second of three future games
shows planned for 2022 there was one
back in march and the final one will be
coming in august as a part of gamescom
the xbox and bethesda games showcase
which might need a naming workshop in
the future if the activision blizzard
deal goes through otherwise that's going
to be one hell of a mouthful will be
held on june 12th at 10 am pt this event
will feature games and announcements
from microsoft's first party studios
including bethesda's roster as well as
third party game announcements
it will likely run for around 90 minutes
that's going off previous presentations
and a tweet from xbox marketing boss
aaron greenberg in terms of what to
expect despite them slipping into 2023
i'd say it's very likely that we'll see
some of redfull the open world co-op
vampire first person shooter coming from
arcane austin as well as starfield
bethesda game studios first new ip in
over 25 years given that the new indiana
jones movie just got a release date at
star wars celebration it's also
plausible that we could get a look at
machine games indiana jones game we know
that xbox is working on a lot of games
around the world but it's not clear
which are ready to show at this event we
last caught a glimpse of hellblade 2 at
2021's game awards so we might see it
pop up again the rumor mill has been
working overtime with regards to what's
next for the gears of war series while
we're waiting for gears 6 some are
speculating that the franchise could be
getting the master chief collection
treatment there's also the question of
fable and perfect dark we've barely
heard anything of the fable reboot since
that initial teaser in 2020 and the only
real update on perfect dark since its
announcement is that crystal dynamics
would be partnering with xbox's the
initiative to work on the game it's fair
to assume with the impending acquisition
of activision blizzard that we'll likely
see some of modern warfare 2 at the xbox
showcase as well xbox has a lot of games
cooking and i'd love to see more from
already announced titles like state of
decay 3 forza motorsport 8 and the outer
worlds 2. regardless with a 90-minute
run time it's bound to be packed with a
lot of games to be excited for pc gaming
show returns once again for 2022 and
will feature arma 4 warhammer 40k space
marine 2 immortality and victoria 3
along with other unannounced games the
show will air immediately after the xbox
and bethesda showcase with more than 45
games in total but we still have several
question marks for this year's summer
gaming events nintendo and ubisoft have
historically hosted their own
presentations in ubisoft's case it's
even hosted two in ea's case we know
there will not be an ea play 2022 event
but their games may still appear in
another showcase but you know where you
can catch all of the big events and the
latest news and announcements right here
on gamespot where we'll be hosting our
own live shows throughout the month of
june not only will we be streaming every
press conference but we'll have pre and
post shows for each one with some
top-notch analysis from the gamespot
team throughout the month we'll also
have interviews with aaa game developers
exclusive gameplay and trailer reveals
and so much more e3 may be gone this
year but there's still plenty to look
forward to and we're super excited to
see what the video game industry has for
us this summer